by the way my hair berries we have some
I got some chocolate chip cookie in my
tummy
berries in my tummy that was nice you're
fresh off the plane from San Francisco I
came back from doing cobs for the
make-a-wish Foundation some ideas from
from our boys Yosef and Tariq yep now
but now Poppy's card got declined up
there you're trying to buy the boy some
ice cream the card got declined that's
all I got a video very nursing Park and
they say can you please pay bride more
money because these car get declines
they're pieces of [ __ ] they're liars and
I hate nope and then I saw you also a
whole new camera taking a picture for
Jake Shields and nobody recognized you
and you kept yelling out gold Birds and
everyone went what that's right so Jake
they said is Jake which noord me and not
me but then they finally go you're a
comic - nope and I said you there that
yeah it was interesting I worked out
with how to work out with dion jordan
number three draft pick in the NFL Oh
years ago years ago years ago he's 30
now he's six seven 260 I'm playing for
the dolphin playing not for the Dolphins
he's playing for the he was playing for
the Raiders his troubles yeah oh okay
and he's that right man we did we did
some foot drills yeah we did some
push-ups stuff like that and please hard
time yeah Tarek was that no I take my
work out no he said you worked out down
Jordan you mean you watched him and then
like a toddler try to keep up don't like
the way you're talking that's what's
going on we were talking right now they
also sent me a video of you work it out
it was body it was body exercises and he
and I and he was like this he goes he
goes like this is I was working out he
goes dude feed it quick and I go yeah
thanks I do some sports you guys you do
a lot of sport then he's they can you
catch a ball cuz let's jump Seattle
let's jump to Seattle and you play for
the Fiats yeah he said let me tackle you
let me come here around the outside
uh-huh and got some speed not happening
dude huh last night D'Elia was show me
pictures of his baby I know let's say a
little old man if he was so I don't know
what I don't know I expect you know a
lot of counselor I'm talking about the
kids or show their kids he was so proud
I know I was getting emotional I was a
cookie chewed I was so proud of him he
said you know silly wild dude he was
every a teddy Whitney like dude leave
this this might be the first time smile
look at this
and show in the video long video to the
Chris I didn't wanna say anything last
night because you're really in the mood
to long though we all sat around for
videos a minute long yeah yeah the other
like we gotta you gotta edit it so we
just see the kids smiling was way too
long I was at Sebastian's house for the
summit thing that he had and Chris was
there Whitney was there and Chris he
kind of backs up and I follow him and he
goes I love my son so much yeah I was
waiting for the joke
there was no joke house he was so proud
man I was a newborn oh you don't even
know what I'm talking about this stage
just wait yeah that's a football dice
it's super mad all the time
just wait - he gets cute yeah I've shown
pics might get at three three months
like get the [ __ ] out of my face exact
what are we doing yeah well at least
he's like snatch your kid I'm like
[ __ ] Gerber baby yes this thing's
cute as [ __ ] and when he's six months
it's gonna have you seen my kids yeah
the baby yeah you showed me photos did I
it's nuts
yeah this one's just steal a man it's
not he's cute as [ __ ] yeah I I wanna see
little babies that some of them are
impossible do not have six kids I can't
get enough oh yeah I can't get enough of
them they're so cute doctor I know what
Dobson babies and gay I want I want to
move in with you in the top babies good
you play the mom part no you know papi
you know Papa makes the bread here Oh
even in like this weird ecosystem Wow
Papa well what do I do
stay at home and do what like the old
like you know you're the guy like you
know hen yeah yeah kind of but you like
you know you like make [ __ ] trinkets
I made you I made you damage we have
advice will I go to you know could you
live long life oh you know I made you
dinner yeah alright dude where are you
gonna be home soon yeah I did
is he still with Demi Moore I'm forgive
me I know he's with Mila Kunis now oh
geez I can see all that damn zhem hey
don't send me teams about how Brendan is
condescending to me okay
don't worry about it they don't realize
we're we're very close and well no they
don't they don't realize oh man
that you're condescending to you but I
never respond to them like you got to
put job and check he's talking at me I'm
like guys guys this is what we do like I
will I will purposely float out
something like especially I'll say
Ashton Kutcher could beat Conor McGregor
I'll say it's TP me it's just gonna
knock out I just throw those out there
cuz you're nuts
and then what I like to do is create a
dynamic where I'll say some [ __ ] you're
egging me now I still I stand by the
fact that Kutcher would tie has no
answer to I mean I'm sorry
Connors no I know you mention it nope
listen straight leg
you missed the port I'm saying the port
wine is this report the point is is that
don't worry about don't worry about that
you have to understand that this hard
time but also you've already lost cuz
your DM and Brian saying that I'm being
mean to well they're all it's all comes
from a good place they'd like you to
make me that just like dude you're older
but it's part of our thing don't worry I
hate when I'm not here and then so many
people dear Mike we did this like oh the
show was terrible I'm like hey wait a
Mike hey man that's my partner okay but
dude definite never leave again I that
all the time
Oh Mike hey hey man hey that's my part
alright dude I feel like you're being
shitty right now I feel like you're
being kind of shitty to sob I'm
defending you're not listen wait you're
not defending me you go look at the
numbers when you're gone it's [ __ ]
durable my friend you're being [ __ ] do
me a favor cuz I was busy
alright but you're being shitty by
saying that never leave a good huh don't
and don't like this shouting it like
that and like as they're driving by in a
car no I beg a thousand being that say
Brendan equals ratings no that's saying
that that's not fair to say it's so
shitty when a successful podcast before
I came come on dude its [ __ ] rock its
[ __ ] rock rock salt Ricky right yeah but
he looks great don't you think
know what I used to I think you look
sweet bald I used to shave my head and I
will and in fact as soon as I'm done
shooting my show don't be surprised by
coming here with a shaved head wouldn't
ice do it all hey papa that was a long
long time your here's a little different
you have to go bald kiss you don't get
shave it that's not ready for shave why
because you'll see the divots well will
you'd have the egg at the bird nest
maybe the bird nest the hair transplants
up no if you shave this this is hanging
on by a [ __ ] thread dude so I don't
see me so light here it's gonna be a
little light you have to salute like
this it is light there isn't it
what's the lightest hold on now it's the
lightest here I I will it's veal I told
you my dad was walking downstairs and he
stopped my head he goes Jesus Christ
I went him winning this you're losing
all your hair on top there it's a bad
day sometimes it's thicker than oh let's
just light on top dude especially there
what happens if I shave a dad be a bad
idea of a pride never girls back be it
sue me like you me bald right here and
then the sides are gonna be you're like
oh ho you gotta get me there you gotta
bake it dude
look at me shame Oh cute oh it's so cute
look at me what I used to fight my head
no no uh-oh that right there no to the
right to the right of that no to the
left right there
whoa Black Betty BAM laughs now you're
here was fresh there dude freshest [ __ ]
dude
they're rolling with a beard yeah young
man right there buddy you're here was a
little light there little light well
does it set before I had my eye oh look
at how cute I was
I wonder why girls like me there's never
been thick though has it since I've
known you
no but what a cutie pie I was
good-looking kid there right you're so
good-looking
you're great man yeah it's my girl cat
your good-looking older man dude well
unfortunately I have lost a lot of it
that's all right yeah that's long that's
the Spike TV guys only award
you know those are words aren't coming
back guys only yeah I used to love those
he's in love watching it yeah
Hollywood went not up in here really
they stopped it not to scare you guys
but the CDC said that it's not a matter
of if it's gonna happen which is when
it's gonna happen
the corona virus spreading here here's
the thing here's the thing
80% of people yet coronavirus are just
fine it's just like um 80% 80% yep
I've makes me feel a lot better now yes
John yeah why why then some become
pneumonia and people are very few die 2%
die thank you
what yeah it's like it's weird it's like
2% I shouldn't ever said have severe
symptoms 80% of people have common cold
symptoms
it's coronavirus and they move on thank
you this is all distraction yep hmm and
that was on NBC Nightly News by the way
by the way uh forget his name but he's
fantastic he's so serious
that's good to hear them yeah don't
worry about it okay go looking for it
but I'm sure it's like not canceling
canceling my Europe tour my brother
really roasted me and sent me those
facts as well doesn't man I'm worried
when I'm your attempt breakout thing is
what sent me all these faster all right
I'll see you soon Europe this was just
fine because one of the head members of
the IOC his name is dick pound and he's
the one that said that the Olympics
could be possibly cancelled in Tokyo
because of the chronovisor
they're gonna give it like two three
must have figured out but then I knew
his they have real bad issues out there
though but then it says that they're
trying to go ahead with it yeah but [ __ ]
stick pound pound over it a lot of
condoms or not we're not playing it safe
you feel about your body killing you
don't get to Olympics by playing it safe
that's right buddy do some [ __ ] check
this out Iran's deputy health minister
he has a corona virus and he was doing a
speech hopefully I have this video read
he looked like me during podcast who's
sweating now yes yes him on a talk show
I know this is before he's coughing
there he looks like a Theon they're
saying he has that I wouldn't trip well
just look at him here he's
this is before he got diagnosed so he's
like passing this around everyone yeah
get infect the common cold though to be
honest looking on it that who gives a
[ __ ] it's really not that big of a deal
it looks terrible
he's weapon I know he looks terrible
he's sweating because he's a serious
cold it's a gift